what did you think when you first got
the support for the red wedding I
probably enjoyed it a little bit too
much actually then is healthy for one
perfect
Lord I knew about it I knew it was gonna
happen I saw some of the guys the day
after they filmed it and I still cried I
was still really shocked
Luna's then that just being stabbed in
the belly was just so pallet at the
table just from behind and just that
that just the anguish of like you can
almost see like it wasn't even like she
was caring about herself dying she
thought about her baby dying first and
it was just wow so how well I read it I
was gutted because Robb Stark was kind
of a favorite of mine and then seeing it
it was even worse also so upset so
you're not allowed to do that I mean I
knew it was going to be brutal but then
you watch it and it's just a lot more
brutal than you expect brilliant and
shocking and marvelous and intense and I
don't think anyone's really recovered
from him yet I also do have friends who
after they read the third book
threw it away and was like there is no
way I'm going to invest any more emotion
in this if that's if that is what is
gonna happen then we're like so angry
about it and this is men Road men crying
tears no we keep having to watch it
though that's the thing it's like you're
like I need to know what's going on I
need to keep watching keep watching me
like I don't want to watch anymore the
whole thing is terrific
that was my daddy's Batman it's the kind
of world where if someone makes a
promise better keepers otherwise there's
some kind of retribution the internet
reaction was the best part of it I
thought that was just incredible how her
how much had people really seemed to
affect a lot of people whose lives and
quite a significant way there's loads of
em reaction videos of people filming
people you see if you feel me it would
have been the same like I was very
shocked it's an amazing episode the way
they filmed it I thought was
unbelievable and I say incredible
episode of television you know in such a
ballsy thing it does sound about the
start family
you've identified with it from the
beginning he's the nobleman and lo Paoli
kills an awful bookworm
you've got mainstay characters who you
know everybody expected to go to
Destin's ought to go further and gone
great puts the whole thing on its head
I mean it's cruel it's cruel but it's
also makes very very good television I
kind of feel and hope that the Starks in
some form or another have a positive end
to this open saga and I think there's
some divine retribution waiting for
worlders somewhere along the way or not
David Bradley was just awesome when we
were shooting the previous scene by we
arrived and he introduced his daughters
he has about 20 daughters with strange
names which sang all the same he did it
75 times because we were there all day
doing this side that Sidewalk carry this
gun and he did it perfectly every time
fantastic we had a terrific director
called an American director called David
Nutter he took a whole week to film like
the massacre scenes and it was just a
bloodbath and I I had to watch it for
the whole week and just look like I was
relishing it and what do you think
Browns he would make it the red wedding
if he'd seen it I think he'd really have
enjoyed wedding everybody's kind of
wedding what do you think's left for the
stocks now it's only a few of them
laughs Walter would say I don't know and
I don't care